Panthers off till next Wednesday with the
NHL holiday break when they'll go to Tampa
tear out of his net ooh couldn't reach it he's
out of the Cav Puck is loose and he makes the
save on the cousins backand oh Nick cousins
had the chance there's much pressure on this
young golender only in his six NHL game look at
he little late getting to the party Panthers dig
it out get it out in front goes off es skate I
don't think cousins realize that Peto was not
back and square to the shot he could have
hung on to that puck maybe an extra half
a second see if they could lift it over top
of them but good work there there you see the
reaction kisar back out there after that
one punch by lomberg Panthers get it out
of trouble kachuck spins into the zone kachuck
to the net with a one-hander and it's a glove
save G he had left in the tank but there's an
outlet pass look at how kachuck there uses that
Big Frame now cut in and now the only thing
he's on his backand and was unable to finish
didn't have any room to really cut in front
Panthers want to make concerted effort and
they did in the first well Vegas they didn't
let him have the puck at all but Vegas very
good up the middle at getting into the Zone
Paul marce saying they're the best team in
the league at it look out in front and they
score it's Stone right in front all alone and
the golden knights get the game's first goal
where the puck goes back in the panther Zone
and the Panthers get caught with two defenseman
in behind there's forsing and then eblad came in
to try and help out and what happens is yep
there you go and the Puck's going to jump
right out in front and by the time the Panthers
can try and recover barkoff and stone makes no
mistake
unreal Vegas wins that board battle and had
a chance here's barbashev again over to Ste
Stevenson Mato stick save made by bosski
the Panthers kill it off here comes eel
with stone eichel knocked Away by a sliding
Gustav forsling what a play and forsling gets
after it bing gets to the net to the backand
he's denied put out in front again and bov
couldn't get it on goal here's Reinhardt
that's hide all right here's the defensive
play by gustaff foring goes down look he gets
that puck first strips ecle of it and then the
forward progress as forsling picks it up
and look at how he just walks around the
veteran defenseman Alec Martinez and goes
to the backand McNab play it ahead it's out
to Center Montour took it away from Stevenson
Here Comes Sam Bennett charging down the wing
Bennett fire score there it is have yourself
a drink the drown is over the Panthers have TI
look at as Bennett just backs off the defense
decides to take that shot short side oh here's
a good look at it right here using McNab as
a screen and just evades the glove Patera and
the Panthers finally tie up this game that glad
knocked it out of the air touched with a high
stick if the Panthers touch it next there'll
be a whistle barov knew that so he let Vegas
play it next heads up by barov and here he comes
barov shoots GL save rebound Stone able to clear
it away chance here by the Florida Panthers
watch here as ryanh Hart gives it the barov
and he just realizes there's going to be back
pressure so get that puck on net Reinhard won
The Face on overy stolen away Stevenson
and barosi got a piece of it Bob got a
piece of it maybe he did with the stick here's
a good angle right here yep yeah you got a got
a little piece of it if you need it in order to
grow they're going to grow a lot because it has
been tough they played some segments of terrific
hockey dominating and you see the shot attempts
today it doesn't get more lopsided than that
one-1 game forsling fire score oh Gustav Let
it Fly and they got the lead gustaff forsling
has put together a pretty good game so far the
defensive side he's broken up some plays look
at that barov just wins it clean now there's the
screen it sets up that's what we keep talking
about you got to take the eyes away from the
goenda all this time getting some pucks
towards the panther net really for the
first time in the game now that they're
behind a little jump McNab sends it to
the net deflected big save of brosi on cter
pure reflexes folks watch this red deflected
and that right P he just kicks it out shot
here by McNab deflected and bosski staying
strong in that net Push by Vegas late in the
period glenan just did get it out kisar for
Hutton at the panther line Hutton gets
through Hutton in front and they score
and Vegas has tied it up late in
the second when the Panthers lost
control of the puck and then the
the quick movement over and then
eblad goes after his man and he gets behind
him and then the centering pass and by that
time there you see the outstretch
Sergey bosi and the game tying
goal stone behind the net now over to eiko in the
corner centering feed glove save Sergey bosski on
maroi able to get that glove on it there you
see leads the Panthers in third period
goal set up on the near side kachuck put
it in front locked away kachuck after it
sweeps it up high Montour verge's got a
chance and he scores oh it's swagalicious
on the power play the Panthers lead it 3
to2 look at how much time and space ver HEI
has and he just takes an extra second to drag
his skate and the puck into a better
shooting position and then after that
it is just shot against glove Talent
against Talent he puts it behind the
nck Reinhardt gloves it down gets hammered
but makes the play to find kachuck now it's
barov Reinhardt turns and shoots he scores
power play goal Sam Reinhardt and it's 4
to2 oh I haven't seen a sauce like
that since my last Tupperware party
the Panthers just moving that puck quickly
finding Reinhardt in their fifth power play
look at the beautiful pass to find Reinhardt
he gets away from the penalty killer look at
the open space turns around KCK with
the screen P got he got a piece of
it Bennett he opened the scoring for
the Panthers tying the game in one last
period in front Bennett what a save by P on the
deflection here's a couple of chances Rodriguez
right out in front this play doesn't happen if
and it holds up a little bit Howen comes the
other way against that clad sa abosi Rebound
in front of MOSI made the same again for the
front of the net to get into the open and then
there's the big rebound and Sergey MOSI came
across at the Vegas bench barov happy to keep
it pinned there with that clock rolling dumped
in on goal P Tera nearly lost it Rodriguez
and he stopped at the net in deep and here
it takes the funny bounce and the young
goenda and who's going to have it he was
trying to leave it there for his defenseman on
the previous play there was no whistle time has
expired the game is over all right there you
go TJ luxmore says that's it so the rats come
down and the Panthers with two
Power Play Goals get the win